britney spears is speaking out about her
2002 breakup with justin timberlake and
the now infamous diane sawyer interview
the following year
ew
can we
in a since deleted post to instagram on
monday the pop star wrote quote do we
dare forget the diane sawyer interview
in my apartment almost 20 years ago what
was with the you're in the wrong
approach geez and making me cry
you've had a rough year
you've had a year that would
test a lot of people it was pretty rough
yeah
yeah it's kind of weird ah
weird hello
um
oh my goodness hello ew
strong britney
um
yeah it was a weird
time
ooh i'm in the cars can we
in the interview sawyer pressed a then
21 year old spears about whether she was
faithful to timberlake referencing
quotes from the singer claiming she'd
only slept with one person he's left the
impression that that you weren't
faithful you
betrayed the relationship
i think everyone has a side to their
story
and
um to make them feel a certain way make
them feel you know
and
i'm not technically saying he's wrong
but i'm not technically saying he's
right either
so
oh this feels really awkward
and in the lengthy post the now 40 year
old grammy winner says she was living
alone at the time in new york city and
didn't want to discuss her already very
public heartbreak quote i lived in my
apartment for a year and never spoke to
anyone my manager put that woman in my
home and made me talk to her on national
television and she asked me if i had a
shopping problem is it an addiction
is it an addiction
no i don't think i think it's an
addiction i think it does put me like it
makes me happy
you know i'll go and i'll buy a hat and
i'll buy some shoes and you know you
feel pretty you feel girly i love that
feeling
but no it's not an addiction
spears only just regained control of her
finances with the termination of her
13-year-long conservatorship which was
mostly overseen by her dad jamie spears
i'm so pleased and proud to say
jamie spears
is no longer a conservator
and in the post speer seems bothered by
the accusation that she had a shopping
problem as her spending habits were in
the conservatorship's hands for a large
portion of her career starting in 2008.
brittany asks quote when did i have a
problem with shopping something i never
shared when i had that big breakup years
ago was that i couldn't talk afterwards
i never spoke to anyone for a very long
time i was in shock pretty lame of my
dad and three men to show up at my door
when i could hardly speak two days later
they put diane sawyer in my living room
spears claims that she had no say in the
matter quote they forced me to talk i
was a baby i was almost 22 and didn't
understand but i [ __ ] know now
i've been in the conservatorship for 13
years
it's a really long time to be in a
situation you don't want to be in
following the post alex weingarten an
attorney for jamie spears released a
statement to e.t denying the singer's
account noting that the interview with
sawyer was conducted in 2003 and her
conservatorship didn't begin until
february 2008. quote mr spears has no
idea what miss spears is talking about
jaime never set up any interview with
diane sawyer and was not present for any
such interview the statement continues
claiming jaime had nothing to do with
his daughter's career at that point and
he was quote completely uninvolved in
the interview quote jamie loves brittany
very much wishes brittany nothing but
the best and hopes that she continues to
seek the help that she needs to stay
safe and healthy
this conservatorship was 13 years during
a time she was building a lot of her
wealth and her fame so it is a very
complicated process that could take
months if not up to a year to totally
detangle her from this conservatorship
the long post from spears comes as the
courts ruled last week that she is free
to handle her finances and conduct
business on her own what's next for
brittany
and this is the first time this could be
said for about a decade
is up to one person
brittany
[Applause]
you